auf und bediene präsentiert von der
leyen für oliver länge tote weniger lang
weg sind vom berner oberland in den
spanischen süden miriam thomann und
ostsee erfüllen sich den traum vom leben
auf einer pferde finca auf einer großen
farm im westen kanadas will familie
ruckstuhl endlich ihr glück finden
mit vier tigern war trainer müller das
abenteuer
er wandert zu seiner freundin alexandra
teetz nach deutschland aus sie bauen
einen tierpark
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach heftigen unwetter zeigt sich
endlich wieder der graue himmel über dem
tierpark im deutschen welt- und zwei
tage vor eröffnung liefern profis den
letzten tierställen dass ziegen haus
ziemlich in den stressigen letzten tagen
hatten alexandra und remo schlichtweg
vergessen den ziegenstall abzuholen
das glück der tüchtigen stand in beiden
zur seite und natürlich alexandras
ansteckende begeisterung für ihren
tierpark vergessen losgefahren mit dem
anhänger und dann wollten wir das
aufladen sich mitnehmen das ist viel zu
groß machte meine geht jetzigen haus
mehr
und ja ich habe sehr glück gehabt dass
die fahrt an dass alle leute unsere idee
mit dem park sehr sympathisch fanden und
gesagt im ok wir organisieren dass das
gartenhaus kommt rocky sitz in der
letzten folge trainierte remo zum ersten
mal mit seinen tigern in der parkallee
alexandra konnte das nicht mit ansehen
und sucht der ablenkung bei ihren mini
schweinchen in kanada ziehen die rub
stuhls kälbchen auf und markus suchte
für sie eine milchkuh auf der spanischen
pferde finca haben sich die auswanderer
gut eingelebt und geschäftspartner
robert könnte sich zum ersten mal seit
über zehn jahren ferien
[Musik]
zum ziegenstall gehören ein gehege und
eine brücke natur und mensch sollen sich
wieder näher kommen
das ist das parkkonzept so sollen kinder
mit den siegen über diese zügen brücke
klettern können nur begehbar ist die
brücke am abend wurde eröffnung noch
immer nicht ich weiß noch nicht genau
wie die konstruktion am ende werden wir
da oben verlaufen
jeder weiß sein bereich der tun muss und
jeder wird einen bereich hoffentlich
fertig kriegen also ich weiß es nicht
aber das schon mal gut also ich bin
besser das helfen alle mit und es geht
nicht irgendein scheich vor allem regen
tvo sitzt im büro und wochenlang hat
sich renault müller um jedes detail
gekümmert
nun aber einen tag vor eröffnung muss er
ganz seinen team vertrauen die musik ja
aber sonst weiß jeder was machen meinte
gar den neongrünen nach hause wo zum
parken möchten ja dann musst du dir
vielleicht irgendwann ab ca als
gelernter koch führt remo der tierpark
besitzer auch ein kleines küchenteam an
[Musik]
jeden dienstag besucht alexandra
ruckstuhl mit ihren kindern in menton
eine spielgruppe die spielgruppe ist
auch eine art physiotherapie für
josephine das mädchen leidet unter einer
seltenen erbkrankheit
sie hat probleme mit den gelenken und
dem knochenbau josef in soll sich so
viel wie möglich bewegen einen
therapieplatz hat die kleine noch nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ich dem noch wissen die rückstoß
nicht ob die kanadische
krankenversicherung die therapiekosten
übernehmen wird
josef in pflege fordert viel
organisation
denn die kleine wird ein leben lang
ärztlich betreut werden müssen aber auch
froh dass es die option ergibt
[Musik]
hallo
die ruckstuhl es haben sich für eine kuh
entschieden und zwar für die kuh mit der
ohrmarke 99 sie ist fünf jahre alt und
hat schweizer wurzeln
sie ist ein zentraler fleckvieh nun bist
du da besitzer alte gewohnheiten legt
man nicht zu schnell ab markus ruckstuhl
bezahlt war in der schweiz machen wir
das so das sind wir gar nicht gewohnt
umgerechnet 2100 franken kostet das neue
familienmitglied und diesen tagen hat
einen klaren auftrag
sie muss ruckstuhl weisen kälber
aufziehen
[Musik]
in saratow auf der finca los angeles ist
etwas passiert was niemand erwartet
hätte
ein pferd ist gestorben einfach so auf
seinem rundgang hat scott lee das tote
pferd entdeckt aber erst an oder ist die
sache klar geführt mit der lunge mit der
luna zweimal bei die links und rechts
nicht da das abendliche programm
ich hatte
[Musik]
das mit drei wochen amt bestätigt
robert ist der geschäftspartner der vor
drei tagen in die ferien gefahren ist
miriam und urs müssen sich entscheiden
ob sie robert benachrichtigen oder seine
rückkehr abwarten und und wie das sache
der politik plakat geschrieben du bist
sind zwar möglich wenn der demut und sie
sind dann ruhig und es kommt aber der
ansatz der vorwurf dass man nicht
richtig und sie mir mit einer situation
so oder so frizberg sind zum teil
konfrontiert und wir haben 20 costa rica
sind dass ich mich schlimm ist längst
seine ob sie oder dritter tage
[Musik]
us-pass li muss die schwierigste sms
seines lebens schreiben
[Musik]
einen abend und eine nacht noch und dann
geht er auf
der tierpark in bay für den schlussspurt
ist gut ein dutzend helfer aus nah und
fern angereist
[Musik]
aus der schweiz haben zwei helferinnen
eine leckerei mitgebracht zum tierpark
gehört auch ein restaurant im gegensatz
zum rest des parks waren restaurant und
küche in gutem zustand mussten kaum
renoviert werden
der koch ist einer von remus zwei
festangestellten dass jens monaten über
das ist schon ein bisschen als besetzen
wenn abstellt dass restaurants und ein
drittel zum umsatz des betriebes
beitragen dass möglichst selten nach dem
wochenend schon mal wieder erklangen ist
und wenn das geld kommt wir müssen
aufpassen mit der geschichte vielleicht
müssen wir auch noch ein paar sachen
kaufen ich weiß es nicht ich dann würde
es hier
macht mal 15 stück
in der schweizer tremor als tierpfleger
und koch gearbeitet also mit dem team
trainieren
die eigentlich lieber aber du da dass es
jetzt eingerichtet ist und durchaus
selber ideen und dabei kann das machen
und so und ich hoffe es kommt wieder das
gemerkt hat dass es nicht nur noch 15 zu
essen ich das eigentlich auch ganz schön
heinz kurze mindest ihre eigene
kampfführung führer muss einfach raus
fertig sind diesmal morgen
es scheint dass einer der mit tigern in
die arena steigt sich durch nichts aus
der ruhe bringen lässt
[Musik]
und bereit ist bis tief in die nacht
außerordentliches zu leisten
[Musik]
weniger schön hoffe so lautet der mensch
nämlich nicht gewinnt ist die vorhand
cross zu machen
vom haus
ruckstuhl sco bekommt ein plätzchen im
stall von markus arbeitgeber
sie sind extrem sensibel
warum also jetzt woche zwei bis sie sich
gewöhnt haben hoffe dass das nicht
milram gespannt auf deine frage
zwei liter
dass sie dennoch nicht ins dioxin baby
baby baby baby
der vater hat noch mehr tiere für den
kleinen familienhof sechs hühner uns
freuen sich über möglichst viele frische
produkte vom eigenen hof megaschön
wirklich schön dick und wohlgenährt und
man glaubt dass die höhe
[Musik]
dpa
im süden spaniens tut sich usb noch
immer schwer die richtigen worte zu
finden
developer contest um gebiete im nachts
wenn du eine ruhige minute hast
telefonieren entschuldige die steuerung
liebe es ist wichtig
es ist nicht spielen wieder städtisches
[Musik]
miriam und uhr suchen trost bei
alltäglichen arbeiten
der verlust eines der tiere geht den
pferdeliebhaber nahe
[Musik]
der tote war leon war das lieblingspferd
von barbara der freundin von
geschäftspartner robert
[Musik]
nun bleibt den beiden nur eines raten
bis robert aus dem fernen costa rica
anruft
[Musik]
vorgelegt
nein die habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
weil sie ohne strom
müssen große kraft
[Musik]
im deutschen bell hat das wetter einmal
mehr umgeschlagen
der morgen der eröffnung ist feucht und
kalt
ein bisschen trist aus da draußen
gegangen jetzt auch im krankenhaus nur
beschaffen also für die psyche zahlen
eigentlich ja gar nicht groß kräfte die
man überhaupt wenn man am samstag so 50
fürs erste haben einfach erst mal haben
wir jetzt noch mal drei stunden zu
arbeiten
1000 der arbeitsstunden liegen hinter
alexandra und remo jetzt geht es nur
noch drei stunden bis zur eröffnung
unzählige freiwillige helfer
unterstützten die beiden tierpark
besitzer nur das wetter spielt einmal
mehr nicht mit
es schneit zucker
gleich kommt hoher besuch und noch immer
findet remo arbeiten die getan werden
müssen so unglaublich dass sheens
matschies mehr als gut
hier haben wir natürlich schön ist
ebenso beruf zu machen
dann fällt der natürlich das hauptrohr
ihn aber dass es erwähnen tatvorwurf
nicht rekordflut gewitter und sturm
das hat mir natürlich eine gewisse und
dann ist es endlich soweit das rote band
darf nicht fehlen
[Musik]
frisch geduscht ist wenig später auch
remo parat eine deutsche fernsehstation
fehlt und der bürgermeister ist nun da
lieber meine damen und herren ich freue
mich ganz besonders dass wir heute an
diesem apriltag hier der erlebnispark
weil eröffnen dürfen und ich finde es
toll dass sie dieses unternehmen die es
so in die hand genommen haben und ich
glaube da das steigert unsere
attraktivität als region um kastellaun
herum ungemach
um jetzt dafür ist noch was sagen also
bevor wir schneiden also das alles wäre
nicht möglich gewesen wenn wir all die
helfer nicht gehabt hätten und vielen
vielen dank an alle die da hinten stehen
und überall vielen vielen dank
ja genau so und aufzüge oma kann endlich
ihr neues zuhause beziehen
[Musik]
auf der pferde finca bemühen sich alle
den betrieb möglichst normal aufrecht zu
erhalten
gäste sind da die reiten lernen wollen
und eine kaufinteressenten hat sich auch
angemeldet ein gast hat sich während der
letzten ferien auf los angeles geradezu
in einen hengst verliebt
[Musik]
konsequent lieber wolle bereich als ich
immer angst dass die nutzer immer wieder
schuhe
morgen wird barbara den andalucia
eklipse zum ersten mal reiten in
reitstiefeln miriam ist ganz allein in
der küche das kochen für viele gäste
hatte ihr anfänglich sorgen bereitet
mittlerweile genießt sie die zeit am
herd etwas gibt und die größten
politischen affäre mit jesse und wenn
das gute und das eincremen männer sogar
ihm aber es gibt berichte stehen mit
gewinnen und glück den saft und später
verlassen
[Applaus]
bisher ganz ordentlich aus nächste
zwischenzeit vergleich mit viktoria
rebensburg 450
meine damen und herren bitte schön
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
eigentlich halten die kanadischen farmer
in dieser gegend kaum hühner sie kaufen
die eier normalerweise im supermarkt
doch nun sind sie von ruckstuhl
bio-eiern begeistert
[Musik]
achtung
bravo zu gott macht alexandra könnte
fast einen kleinen handel aufziehen
also machen dass man einfach quasi so
viel einfacher das muss fort doch in
zahlen und denn der rechte schenkung
kollegin elena nahe weiches habe mubarak
auch diese mentale rinn hat sich gut
eingelebt alexandra hat sie auf den
namen ruby getauft
da ich nur ein besser kommt und mit ruby
ist alexandra hochzufrieden
mittlerweile gibt die gut 20 liter milch
pro tag und die einst halb verhungerten
weißen kälbchen haben den ruby eine neue
mutter gefunden
zwei fahrstunden von zu hause entfernt
ist markus mit 200 rindern unterwegs
angeführt von downloaden chef cowboy und
arbeitgeber von markus schreiben sie die
rinder auf die sommerweide willow creek
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das sind dafür halten
schweizer haben den ruf gute arbeit zu
sein meint markus ist zu einer
[Musik]
die hochgelegenen sommerweiden gehören
dem staat farmer haben beide recht
[Musik]
am ziel das traditionelle pferderennen
der ostschweizer cowboy schafft des auf
platz drei einen abschluss
[Musik]
zum ersten mal im eigenen tierpark am
nachmittag der eröffnung trainiert remo
seine vier sibirischen tiger vor
publikum
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in rom ostia arena haben rund 280
zuschauer platz
das erste mal in der eigenen arena für
einmal getraut sich auch alexandra das
training anzuschauen
also machen wir die tür auf da kommt man
mal was sie macht
ok mit dem marienplatz jede t hat seinen
platz
das ist wegen der schulklasse weil wenn
sie alles dann können dann geht das viel
viel schneller akademie camino hhk
[Musik]
ok go i
das ist nämlich das aus einem besten
kann und ist er draußen vertrauensbeweis
weil das macht er nur wenn es sich wohl
fühlt wie gut der junge so jetzt bist du
von alleine wieder aufgestanden
normalerweise schlechter dann einfach
und wartet wie sich wieder kommen gut
geht das ist nur im kopf ich bin
gleichzeitig neues erstellt und regnet
nur das höre ich zu gern so aufpassen tv
schnell denn wir haben
und so lassen was wir heute auch gut
sein dh sie müssen noch einmal kommen
halben jahr klappt es besser indem man
uns ja super da geht es gemacht wie wie
anfänger eigentlich cool ist sie das
messer hätte wirklich nie das macht er
nur wenn er sich wohl fühlt und dass ich
sie also wenn ich sogar zu kunden können
dann war es richtig gut weggegangen
langsam neigt sich der ereignisreiche
tag dem ende zu und am abend bringt der
wilde april da ein paar sonnenstrahlen
also fiel war es nicht aber ich habe
okay wir sind glaube passiert glück nur
zahlt doch wir haben 60 hast du dir
gewünscht gerichts kann ich okay danke
nochmal öffentlich eigentlich aber ich
habe ganz schön geld ja und es cool dass
alle nicht nach hause gehen und wir
dürfen hier dass die sonne scheint
[Musik]
rinder auf die sommerweide hochzutreiben
ist nicht nur für den ostschweizer
cowboy sondern für alle das große
ereignis des jahres
und dazu gehört auf dem heimweg trotz
der tiefen temperaturen
traditionsgemäß ein bad
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das abenteuer geht weiter
in den nächsten tagen treibt markus noch
weitere herden auf die sommerweide und
die bande zu seinen neuen kollegen wird
immer stärker ist die haie wieder finden
shape geschützt sein
[Musik]
doch es ist kurz vor dem schlafengehen
regelmäßig massiert alexandra josephine
auf spielerische art und weise macht sie
mit der kleinen übungen die ihr ein
schweizer therapeut beigebracht hat das
schönste war verbessere aber dann wird
es wird sowieso schlimmer war damit der
kleine körper das halt da weiß ich dass
das sicher dass man daher so lange wie
möglich bewegt hatte
jene zeigen wir doch mal nach ihm da ist
doch mittragen und andere war sich wir
entwickeln gibt es keine garantie dass
das nimmt sich sorgen machen
wahrscheinlich mal genauso bald jeden
tag sorgen und die lena machen und
monster sehen und ja doch einfach mal
aus dir alles weiterhin gut entwickelt
dombret auf der pferde finca in
andalusien der gast auf das versetzt
vergesst nicht nur ganz ruhig das pferd
ist zwar ein geräten zur sicherheit aber
führte gestüts bereite adrian den hengst
an der leine
der fünfjährige hengst eklipse ist gut
einen kleinwagen wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
barbara prammer und der andalucia
harmonieren perfekt
[Musik]
gestützt auf uns kann heute sein erstes
pferd verkaufen
[Musik]
das und nicht zuletzt hilft ihnen die
freude über den verkauf ein klein wenig
über die trauer um den verstorbenen
wallach region hinweg das pferd blieb
sowie zu diesem preis verkauft wie
abgemacht zahlungsmodalitäten abgemachte
bei den glücklich dass das so wunderbar
ist ein wechselhaftes und gratuliere
eine überglückliche frischgebackene
pferdebesitzerin
[Musik]
krebse und ein noch glücklicherer pferde
verkäufer jetzt kann us seinem
geschäftspartner wenigstens auch eine
gute nachricht übermitteln in der
nächsten und letzten folge von offen
davon beziehen merian und muss endlich
ihr eigenes häuschen
robert ist aus den ferien zurück die
beiden freunde reden über den tod von
pferd leon der tierpark in deutschen
bell ist gut angelaufen
ich freue mich dass sie hier so
zahlreich erschienen sind und ein großes
ereignis steht an
in der tiger arena wird hochzeit
gefeiert
der afrikanische milch übernimmt dabei
eine wichtige aufgabe erntezeit in
kanada markus trifft erbsen
und die familie feiert erntedankfest im
großen wie wir fleisch
[Musik]
muss nicht die ganze gefüge mit träumen
ja
die villa ist
sid
[Musik]
huf und tv infos präsentiert wurde der
leyen für oliver längert oder weniger
lang weg sind